[Music]
young Hollywood party happy to be here
yeah signify what young Hollywood is
thank you
oh my gosh it's an honor to be here to
be completely ask you Sam to update what
do you know right now I know a lot no I
don't know much but hopefully we start
shooting the sequel soon and hopefully
the trailer after that but I'm yeah we
got a lot coming how do you read the
script no not yet I know maybe they mean
maybe not
yes yeah you did tell us that you
auditioned for the role of Prince Erik
Holly Bailey is here tonight does that
mean anything I mean it could mean
something it could it could not I don't
know I don't want to spoil anything you
know I don't want to pull a Tom Hollands
or anything but yeah are you a prince
Eric no I don't know who knows I mean
have you screen tested the world's crazy
animal you know I don't you know
chemistry tested maybe man you never
know you know who knows what would you
love most about playing Prince Eric well
you know my first show um I started out
doing the school theater so I think that
was a little murmur with my first show
and I was flounder and I remember when I
was funner I was dying to be Prince Eric
but I was too young so I feel like now
I'm at the age where I'm able to be
Prince Eric's I and that would just be a
dream come true to you know do it so
have you met Halle yet I have not so I'm
excited it's gonna be a great night
thank you so much
you
[Music]